[Music]
hello minimizers welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists so i was sifting
through my kitchen cabinets last week
trying to jettison any and all expired
food items as i searched i found a
shocking amount of condiments packages
and even over-the-counter medications
that have outlasted their use by date
which got me thinking why don't we talk
about this
on the podcast so on today's episode
we're going to talk about expired things
things like expired food and expired
material possessions and expired daily
habits then this thursday on the
minimalist private podcast ryan and i
are going to take it beyond the home and
talk about expired careers expired
obligations expired home towns and even
expired relationships you can check that
out at patreon.com
the minimalists your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free because
advertisements suck our first question
today is from kendra on facebook
i keep a whiteboard on my fridge to jot
down the expiration dates of food
how can we systematically check the
expiration dates of other parts of our
lives
i thought this was a great question to
start with ryan so we're talking about
expiration that's what got me looking
into this
what did you notice when you were going
through your your cabinets and and
fridge and did you have a bunch of
expired stuff like i did yeah and it's
interesting because like i did not think
i was going to have anything ex because
mariah did such a good job of in the
refrigerator like she's very strict with
um
with expiration dates mainly because she
has stomach issues so
you know like past a certain date um
you start to get these histamines and
like it upsets her stomach like she goes
out of her way to like make sure there's
no old anything in the refrigerator
except for all my sauces
i am king sauce i love the sauces so he
really is the sauce king so let me guess
you opened it up and you started looking
and you were devastated by how many of
these things were expired like i was
there was there was a few there was like
there was some chili paste there was
like some salad dressing uh there was a
hot sauce there was only three or four
things in there but i will tell you
um a lot of the sauces are coming up on
expiration dates so that just means i
have to like you know chug a bunch of
sauce over the next month or two
but really where the the majority of the
expiration
expired stuff came from was vitamins
like that was
because like what will happen is you
know someone recommends like hey take
this 5 hdp or whatever it is and you
start taking it and then you kind of
kind of falls out of your routine so
you're like well i'll just hold on to
those in case i ever have a symptom that
that vitamin you know might be able to
to to uh you know help and yeah i was
going through and like there was just a
ton of like that was the vast majority
of it was expired vitamins other than
that
um that was it no medications oh i take
that back we did have like an unopened
box of nyquil daqua that was expired
but i never really i don't know man like
you can still take it for up to a little
bit after the expiration date right
right and so that's what i want to
clarify today because well this term
expiration date is often misused or well
it's a generic term and so i have some
articles here we're going to put a link
to both of these in the show notes
there's one from the new york times
which i'm not going to read but it's
called the food expiration dates you
should actually follow we'll put a link
to that in the show notes but i have
something else from webmd
and this is called food expiration dates
what to know
and uh so it goes into talking about
understanding food expiration dates and
i think the the thing to to really think
about here is that well it's this first
line in the new york times article
expiration dates are not expiration
dates
that that's actually says the first
thing you should know so from that
article it talks about how
these expiration dates other than infant
food are completely voluntary so you
don't have to it's not like i always
thought in my mind like oh i'm supposed
to
you know or these companies are supposed
to put an expiration date they have to
by law fda must no that's not true they
do it because well there's a different
bunch of different kinds of dates so in
this webmd article there's a sell by
date which means what well it means the
store wants to sell it by a certain date
otherwise they take it off their shelves
because they know it's getting ready to
spoil things like milk and yogurt and
cream and eggs and lunch meat and salad
mixes but then there is the
best if used by date which is different
from the sell by date so
it's best if it's used by it doesn't
mean it has to be used by things like
canned goods crackers cookies spices etc
so your food may be good for months or
even years after this date with proper
storage then there's the use by date so
that's also different from a best if
used by date this gets really confusing
right oh yeah so eat food by this date
for best quality now it turns out with
your medication and your supplements
that's also the case so i texted a
doctor friend of mine dr tommy wood this
morning and we were talking about it and
he was saying well yeah if you want them
to if they tend to lose potency after
their expiration date that said they're
not immediately rendered useless or
stale or bad or anything like that it's
that a lot of medications and
supplements they're no longer optimal
for what you're trying to treat or help
or symptoms so when you think about it
like i uh
when i was so i went to the fridge and
then i started going through the the
medicine cabinet and i saw this canker
sore really like i got a canker sore
back in 2013
and i bought like canker raid that's the
last time you had a canker sore yeah
that's incredible i used to get them all
the time they're just ulcers in your
mouth right so when i stress i get i get
canker sores i get them in my small
bowel and i can't really use canker aid
on that right
and anyway so i looked at it and it said
expired 2014.
why was i holding on to it well
emergency item that's at least what i
told myself right and so to get back to
kendra's question here
yes i think we can talk about
expired food but i think it goes beyond
the food it goes to supplements and
medications and then i think it goes
elsewhere
in the home
so
i'd encourage you to check out both of
these articles because it goes through
the use by date what is an actual
expiration date
and then there's a quality assurance
date as well which is like for food
safety
ultimately here's the the general
synopsis of this webmd article once food
arrives in your home it's good for a
certain length of time this guideline is
only an estimate around 90 percent of
the people in the united states don't
understand that expiration dates
are on food labels they throw away food
that is still good if it could be frozen
or and used later
and so
they have some examples in here for
example milk is good seven days in your
fridge store in the back of your fridge
for the coldest temperatures eggs are
good for three to five weeks like milk
you should store eggs in the back of
your fridge ground meat and poultry are
good for only one or two days in your
fridge if you plan to use it later
freeze it right away so this is one one
two days when it's thawed out this is
interesting because the so you go to the
grocery store they've got all the
chicken beef and all the meat you know
sitting in the in the cooler
that's refrigerated yes so they have to
sell that within the next couple days
otherwise they have to throw it out
probably yeah interesting okay i mean i
i'd suspect some stores probably don't
you follow that yeah but um yeah the
thing is you can freeze it though and
then obviously it's long for it it works
for much longer it's fine for much
longer so
uh lunch meat is good for two weeks
before it's opened and three to five
days after it's open cooked meat and
poultry are good for three to four days
dry rice or pasta are good for one to
two years in your pantry steaks are good
for three to five days in your fridge
canned fruit is good 12 to 18 months in
your pantry once open it's five to seven
days i'm gonna go back to this new york
times article real quick and just
highlight something here ryan
uh let's start with the things you
definitely don't need to worry about
vinegars honey vanilla
and other extracts sugar salt corn syrup
and molasses will last virtually forever
with little change in quality regular
steel cutter rolled oats will last for a
year or so before they start to go
rancid but park cooked oats or insta
notes can last nearly forever
same with grits versus instant grits
so there are some things that last
forever but that throws up my skepticism
and antenna right yeah because
nothing lasts forever sure and so i have
to think about
expiration dates with respect to food
and if i have food in my home that never
expires it's probably not really food
dude this makes me think about um i got
a chiropractic buddy chiropractor buddy
in missoula montana and he took a happy
meal
hamburger french fries
put it in a um display case
and like he basically like the plaque
just says the date of when he put it in
the case
and
there is no mold or anything like
growing on it it's so weird terrifying
and i asked him i was like oh is this
like a you know like a vacuum seal or
something like is that how you're you
know
he's like no he just picked up the
the case like it's just a cover it's
there's no vacuum seal on it wow and
it's just been sitting there for
at least five or so yeah going on six
years now it's crazy
well let's eat this
yeah we eat a lot of things that aren't
food right we did the minimalist diet
episode on on the minimalist uh private
podcast
uh with ben greenfield and uh my wife
backs who's a dietitian nutritionist and
she used to do food safety for
university and even she's you know
anytime i i have ocd so like if i see
the expiration date i'm like we gotta
get rid of this she's like well no it
still has this many days or and so uh
understanding an expiration date i think
it's really important it doesn't mean
you have to immediately waste the thing
yeah throw it out it may still be good
beyond its supposed expiration date
however these are indicators they're not
a hundred percent certain yeah but i'd
like to take kendra's question here and
move it beyond the kitchen beyond the
medicine cabinet she says she keeps a
white board on her fridge to jot down
the expiration dates of food but how can
we systematically check the expiration
dates of other parts of our lives so
what other parts of our lives
well i we have some rules in place yeah
kendrick you go to the minimalists.com
rulebook you can download the free 16
rules for living with less it's a free
ebook that you can download there at the
website and we use some rules that
essentially allow our things to expire
as well yeah so one of those rules is
the seasonality rule yeah and i think
that's a perfect way to start if you go
to any room in your house you go to your
closet
right now it's fall have i used this in
the last night you pull out a sweater
have i used in the last 90 days well no
i didn't use it in the summer obviously
right
and am i going to use it in the next 90
days well yeah if you are going to use
it in the next 90 days
great then it's not expired yeah if that
thing's been in your closet for three
years
it's probably expired yeah maybe your
seasonality rule at home is yeah 12
months the 12-month 12-month rule
whatever it is right these are uh these
are yeah these are ways that you can
keep expiration dates um in your
household with with other things besides
your food yes indeed so let's let's
think about when you go throughout your
house or some things of course aren't
going to expire you have toilet paper it
doesn't expire i call them just for win
items like i buy a case of toilet paper
or i'll buy certain things just for when
i need them and then there are the
emergency items
these are just in case items that you
hope you'll never have to use
now
it turns out that sometimes we can use
that rule like i was for the canker raid
i was using that to justify holding on
to that thing that if i was honest with
myself i wasn't actually
going to use it it had been several
years
i had gone without using it i could have
given myself permission to let go and so
last week i obviously gave myself
permission to let go of anything that
was wildly expired was past its
potential potency
when it comes to medications or
over-the-counter things or even food
salsas condiments etc i saw some things
in there that were just i was shocked
because i used to go in every 90 days i
would do the seasonality rule for my
condiments and stuff even because i
don't keep mini condiment i am not the
sauce king like ryan i aspire to be able
to eat all the sauces he does yes please
list your favorite sauces in the
comments below so i can try them
by the way we're streaming this live for
the first time for our patrons the
intentionalist level and up so
intentionalists uh true fans vips and so
if you're participating on youtube
right now you want to let us know some
of the things in your fridge that are
expired
let us know well you can just comment in
alabama we'll pull that up she'll curate
that and she'll get it together for us
but we do have a question here from ryan
in seattle when we're talking about
consumables here i am looking at some
consumables that
were expensive to buy and i have pretty
well resolved to not buy them again
and there are high quality type things
so i have like some shaving oil and uh
really high quality shaving cream things
like that and things that i i do use but
so infrequently that
it's it kind of adds up to being clutter
and i wonder how you guys feel about
getting rid of those type things
and what advice you have for
just things that were expensive once
that
i i don't feel like i'll clutter my life
with those type things again but i i
it's hard the idea of parting with them
now is kind of hard to wrap my head
around
so speaking of excuses to hold on to
things i think this is one of the like
easiest excuses to use as well i paid a
lot of money for that i remember when i
was going through my packing party and
letting go of a lot of that stuff um it
was hard to let go of these expensive
items um but yeah i think that uh well a
you've got to look at sunk costs so
sometimes you spend a lot of money on
something you're never gonna get that
money back out of it um you know
ultimately uh uh
the expiration date on these shaving
oils if it's
if it's expired it's expired it doesn't
matter how much it costs
um but if you know if you're using it
every 90 days or whatever your
seasonality rule is yeah hang on to it
that's fine but using the excuse of it
costs a lot of money that is uh
well it's just an excuse amen let's talk
about what is clutter because he's
talking about how these things might be
clutter well for me i have my own
definition of clutter in my life if it's
a burden or if it gets in the way of the
things that add value to my life then it
is clutter now obviously what's clutter
for me is different for you and anyone
else who's watching or listening to this
right and so understanding right now
it's clearly a burden you wouldn't be
calling in and asking about it but that
sunk cost that ryan is talking about you
have to let that go the sunk cost as
soon as you've spent the money on it
it's gone now the question is what can i
do with that am i able to resell it well
probably not with shaving cream and
things like that yeah but if it is a
burden and you're only using it
intermittently out of obligation well i
guess i spent a lot of money so i should
use this
well here's another rule that comes into
play the spontaneous combustion rule we
just did a whole episode about that i
encourage you go back and take a listen
to the entire episode because the
question we asked with the spontaneous
combustion rule is
if this were to spontaneously combust
would i replace it and obviously for
ryan the answer is hell no i definitely
wouldn't replace it yeah if the answer
is hell no well then i'm definitely
gonna let it go ryan i hope to see you
in not you well i hope to see you as
well ryan i'll be there but ryan in
seattle we're going on the love people
use things toward the second half we
have 11 more cities seattle vancouver
san francisco los angeles we'll be in
the midwest at some point minneapolis
and chicago
and columbus and toronto and we'll also
be on the east coast as well we'll be uh
new york city boston washington dc we
got special guests secret guests in
every city including seattle we hope to
see you there the minimalists.com
tour to find a city near you
or if you're ryan in seattle we're just
going to send you a couple tickets we'll
uh we'll see you there make sure you say
hi
ryan what time is it you know what time
it is it's time for the lightning round
where we answer your text messages you
can text your questions and comments to
937-202-4654 yes indeed now during the
lightning round that's what ryan and i
do our best to answer questions with a
short shareable less than 140 character
response we put the text to these
minimal maxims in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pithy answers on
social media if you like and now you can
find all of our minimal maxims in one
place thanks to our good friend jessica
lynn williams
that's minimalmaxims.com
ryan darryl has a question for us what
can we do about expired sources of
content
maybe you've read the same blog for
years and the viewpoint narrative and
opinions have now expired for you when
is it time to look elsewhere for content
i have a pithy pithy answer here maybe
well let's talk about this so maybe
content's the problem right so here's my
pithy answer less content more
contentment
isn't it the content that's often making
us miserable yeah the fire hose of
information the breaking news the
chirons
the
well the
never ending we call it a twitter stream
right right and try it's like if you go
to a remembering
aspen recently yeah and like we went
down to the stream there and it was
great we did we literally dipped our
toes in the water we actually put our
whole feet in the water
but imagine if you were trying to
consume or touch all of the water
you never could no and that's that's why
we feel so that's part of the reason why
we feel so discontent is because we're
trying to consume it all we think that
we should
consume it and i think it's making us
miserable and so maybe it's not about
replacing it at all
maybe it's about simply
doing without maybe when you have gotten
rid of something it's not about
searching for a replacement i know when
i was letting go of those expired items
in my fridge and i think it's a metaphor
for all the other items in our house
i let go of those things it wasn't like
oh now i need to go hurry rush the store
replace these things sometimes i might
need to replace it but just because
you've gotten rid of something doesn't
mean you must replace it sometimes
you'll feel more contentment more peace
if you do less because
doing less is not about the doing it's
about the less yeah
you know it's it makes me think about
how uh people who
rely on one source of
news or a blog or whatever it is that's
that's a way
to really put yourself in a bubble
and so you know if you're relying on one
source for anything i think that's
probably problematic in a way
um unless it's the minimalist podcast
that's right exactly
yes it's a very diverse
uh diverse thoughts and uh yes we keep
you updated with all the breaking news
can you imagine we're moving on to our
breaking news segment now oh my goodness
i cannot imagine but here's the thing no
matter what though
if you're clinging to something um it's
it's going to be a bit of a detriment so
here's my pithy answer clinging corrupts
contentment
so anything that you're clinging to
you're actually ruining that experience
so if you're clinging to just uh you
know some blog that you've always
read and it served you 10 years ago and
now you're just clinging to it because
it's a habit um you're actually ruining
that experience of reading the blog so
yeah don't cling that's such a such a
good point because
there are some things that really did
serve us and i think it's most extreme
when you look at like
humans
and post-pubescent humans like there are
things that really added value to my
life when i was five years old yeah i
used to really like nickelodeon magazine
and i liked he-man figurines right yeah
skeletor was my favorite
of course he was
so i um
in fact by the way there was this uh
there's i think it was a patron who
reached out i sent you the meme they
sent me oh yeah yeah um oh yeah that's
like a very common meme it's like uh
it's like it's an interesting fact
that that it's kind of a funny fact and
then it puts a weird thought in your
head and then like yeah so it's skeletor
like here's this interesting fact right
and then it shows i'm running away and
he's like until next time right in fact
i can't say because we haven't i'll save
it for the uh the maximum episode this
week because i don't want to ruin our
perfect record this week with uh with no
curse words all right but uh oh um
alabama i think we probably have some
comments or some folks from uh from
patreon who want to weigh in on the live
stream
we do irene wants to know what can we do
to tell that we've entered a new season
in life and it's time to let hobbies
friendships and old dreams expire um
yeah and so whenever i'm i'm looking at
a material possession i start with
with does this add value to my life yeah
now how do i how do i even quantify that
well it's not about quantifying it it's
not even intellectual exercise
it's a emotional exercise and if i have
that sort of heart feeling that oh this
isn't serving me anymore or maybe it
never served me at all it was something
i thought this hobby i really wanted to
try because i saw other people having
ecstatic fun with rafting or fly fishing
or snowboarding and that's wonderful for
them
in fact i was on the beach yesterday
with backs we're we do every other
wednesday off and we just you know go to
the beach or somewhere and just sort of
be we don't do a whole lot it's kind of
like a terrence malik film we're just uh
just sort of wandering around a little
bit and there's no point to what we're
doing
and i saw this guy who was practicing
kite surfing
but he was doing it on the beach he
wasn't actually in the water doing he
was just like testing out the
the kite yeah yeah and what was so fat
i'm sure you've seen people because you
go surf all the time sure but what was
fascinating about that my first
inclination was oh i should do that
right
and maybe it'd be great
but let's say i felt like i was
obligated i'm supposed to do that i need
to have a hobby
well that's exactly what you were
talking about with the question earlier
from daryl now i'm clinging to it yeah
yeah you know it's interesting i don't i
would never feel
i don't know i don't feel comfortable
telling anyone
here should be the expiration date
here's how long it had you know what i
can tell you an answer to that question
of you know how do we know it's a new
season
if you know you know
you know i mean if you push a t that's
right if you know you know i mean really
it comes down to uh
it would be really easy and simple
to have these very clear-cut expiration
dates especially when it comes to our
job when it comes to our uh friendships
when it comes to a hobby
but ultimately you gotta look at like
how are you how are you feeling are you
feeling discontented if you are then
that's probably a symptom that maybe it
is time for a new season but certainly
you don't want to
sit there and look in the mirror and ask
yourself should i be stressing out right
now
should i be anxious about i mean that's
that's the uh that's the worst thing
that you could do so yeah i mean if you
know you know
i love that question ryan should i be
stressing out right now because as soon
as you ask it you realize how absurd the
question is right
and you realize well no obviously like
worrying is just praying for something
bad to happen in the future right you
can tweet that podcast sean but what i
will tell you is that by asking that
question should i be stressing out right
now it's like well
the answer is always going to be no to
that unless there is some sort of
immediate danger
fear threat
against us then of course yes i should
be stressing out but even then at that
point i don't actually need to ask the
question yeah if a lion comes busting
through that door i'm not like hey ryan
should i be stressing out right now
no i'm going to be stressing out
immediately yeah but we we're now
treating everything like it is a lion
busting through the door oh you know
that person looked at me funny when i
got in the elevator
because uh they weren't wearing a mask
and i was or something we have an
elevator here actually yes but it
doesn't take you to this floor strangely
anyway i know we have a bunch more
questions from the live stream and
patrons we'll get there on this week's
maximum episode but i know emma you have
something for us right here are some
voicemail comments and insights from our
listeners hi my name is erin and i live
in salt lake city and first off i wanted
to thank you
all the minimalist team for your podcast
it continually helped me simplify my
life and to recognize that simplicity
and minimalism is a journey and not a
destination it's something that i have
to continually work at
during the clothing episode you touch a
lot on intentional purchasing and i had
a tip i've been using lately that i hope
can help other listeners express
intentionality when they need to buy
things
so what i do is i keep a note on my
phone of questions that i have to answer
look at and answer before i purchase
something and it can be anything from
groceries to clothing and you can come
up with whatever questions work for you
but here are mine as an example
so the first one is uh and hopefully
it's a podcast favorite uh does this add
value to my life the second one can i
afford it the third can something else
do the same job or substitute well
enough so hopefully it
forces me to be a little bit creative
and see if i can find something already
that will work
fourth will i use it frequently enough
to warrant buying it so it helps me
consider if it's something that maybe i
can borrow or rent instead the fifth can
i buy it used if i do need to buy it and
then the sixth does it fall in line with
my principles um so for instance i'm a
vegan for ethical reasons so i when i
buy food i choose to buy plant-based
food um if it's clothing it's something
that i
hopefully can find sustainably produced
and that will last me a long time
or if it has
any type of packaging that hopefully
it's recyclable and then lastly
which kind of ties back to the first one
do i need it or do i just want it and if
it's something i just want then it needs
to go back on the shelf
hi josh and ryan my name is chris urban
and i'm a computer tech calling in from
chico california
i was listening to your organizing
episode and wanted to give a tip to
tonya who called in wanting to sort her
digital files
you guys mentioned cloud storage as an
option which is great for some i
personally dislike cloud storage because
i never want to risk my personal privacy
if there was a security issue with the
cloud service
i'll be facing
sorting my own digital files this month
and we'll be doing it with two hard
drives which will be the same model of
ties and will be in raid 1. without
going into too much detail raid 1 is a
way to set up hard drives to be mirror
images of each other every time a file
is added to one it goes to the other
also it appears as one drive in the
operating system
if one drive fails the other will still
have the data it's a great way to back
up important data and avoid the cloud
i realize this sounds very complicated
but it really isn't search online for
how to set up raid 1
and i am sure you will find plenty of
guides all right joe before we get to
our added value segment this week we
want you know we got a bunch more
surprise questions over on patreon this
thursday that's the minimalist private
podcast
beth over on patreon says your private
podcast always lightens my day and
increases my understanding of what
simplicity is most of all your joy and
laughter gets right to me keep your
passion burning josh and ryan hmm ryan
that's a wonderful testimonial that
really is you're so popular thanks beth
i know i tell you all the time uh real
quick right here right now here's one
thing that's going on in the life of the
minimalists if you're watching a live
stream you know we we already talked
about this a little bit before we
started recording
but um
you know when you're watching one of
your favorite shows like game of thrones
ryan
and just one of your favorite characters
dies mid-episode and they kill the
dragon queen
[Music]
killing off one of our favorite
characters this week yeah
sadly emma the immigrant is repatriating
back to canada
although she'll still be with us in
other capacities helping us out with all
kinds of things she just won't be here
for these minimal and maximal episodes
but fear not alabama's gonna pick up the
uh the questions starting next week but
uh i think we need to give emma a round
of applause
by the way she has a wonderful podcast
it's called the curious one podcast
we'll put a link to it in the show notes
or you can find it wherever beautiful
podcasts are sold yeah man it turns out
it's uh it's really hard to uh immigrate
to america yeah it turns out it's not so
easy let's talk more about that on the
maxwell episode because we had some
serious challenges so generally i have
this um
well this uh blind confidence about
things and so it's an american thing
yeah i think that's part of it yeah and
it works really well most of the time
like hey i've never made a movie but
let's go ahead and try it right yeah
but sometimes when you try to hire
someone from a foreign land it's much
much more difficult than you would think
we'll save that for the private podcast
though for added value this week ryan
there are some things that never expire
you know um
radiohead it all went downhill after
okay computer they say
but that's not true they're two of their
best albums are kid a and amnesiac yeah
and they those were you know that was
great those two were supposed to be a
double album oh really and they decided
like well we don't want to do the whole
double album thing so they just released
them separately oh wow i think it was in
2000 and in 2001 they they separate they
separated them and they they were two
separate projects even though they were
recorded in the same sessions together
well they've just re-released it as a
triple disc
i don't have discs anymore but yeah it's
30 songs so there are other songs that
didn't make the original cut
and it is i mean i was just going back
to it it's like a masterpiece i i was it
makes you think like oh these should
have been together as one project the
whole time i was telling podcast shawn
that i think he would enjoy because i
know he's a big james bond fan but it
almost feels like they made
a soundtrack to a james bond film that
doesn't exist i feel that with a lot of
the music of radiohead in this time
period let's check it out on the maximum
episode we'll play you out with uh one
of the new songs unreleased songs called
follow me around
and they uh they just called the album
kid amnesia
okay we'll put a link to that in the
show notes by the way we have a bunch
more surprise questions this week like
how do i let go of a 30-year
relationship that has expired how do i
let go of expired beliefs and an expired
hometown and what would life look like
if we put an expiration date on
everything plus a million more questions
for the minimalists and if you want to
hear all that check out the minimalist
private podcast this week visit
patreon.com
the minimalist to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app you also gain immediate access to
hundreds of hours of private archives
recordings of live events exclusive home
tours and our private community of
thousands of open-minded minimizers like
you you can follow the minimalists on
tiktok instagram facebook and twitter at
the minimalists if you have a question
comment or minimalism tip for our
podcast email a voice memo to podcast at
theminimalists.com and if you want our
show notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list on our website you'll also
receive our simple sunday newsletter for
free and if you leave here today with
just one message
let it be this
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
every little thing
you think that you need every little
thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine
without it